[Music]
okay lynn strauss and welcome to how the
light gets in tell us a little bit about
your career as a philosopher it's been a
very long career a very luscious career
what's is there a thread connecting your
work
well there's a story about i mean i
meant to be against stories and
narratives but there is a reason why i
did it which is
i read islamic studies for two years at
cambridge
where basically i was just growing my
hair and taking drugs
but um
then i thought got bored with that
because it wasn't well taught and took
up social and political science
and after a year of that i thought this
is a building that begins on the fourth
floor you know where's the basement
where's the foundation must be in
philosophy and i had a certain
disincentive to do it because my father
was doing it and
was famous and all that but but that is
how i got into it and then i just got
hooked i intended originally to go back
to social political science but i really
got hooked yeah
what was it like growing up in a
household with a famous father a famous
philosopher peter strawson very low
impact i mean never really impinged so
did you know did you not talk philosophy
with him at home at all no not before i
started trying to do it and
only a bit afterwards
so it was mostly a concern with
foundations and the kind of like key
questions behind
the assumptions behind social sciences
that is what made me change in fact my
tutor at the time gary runseman
suggested that that's what i ought to be
doing so i did it right
so i know you said you have haven't
worked on this for a while but free will
obviously was a big topic in your career
and you've made the argument that free
will
uh in an extension moral responsibility
cannot really exist unless we control
who we are
and given that that's not really
possible for most of us
we cannot really achieve it we don't
have control of our genes or how we get
brought up and so on
so
what do we do if we if we get rid of
that
idea given that it's so pivotal to
society well
we can't
so no worries
um i mean that's that's as it was a
state step two of what i tend to say
about free which is that on the one hand
there's this a priori proof
that it's this well i mean let's let me
just slightly rephrase um i don't know
what free will means really but the
thing i say is impossible is some what i
call ultimate moral responsibility right
i mean and it's it's not it's a pretty
obvious argument really you do what you
do because of the way you are
in any given situation okay
so to be ultimately responsible for what
you do you have to be ultimately
responsible for how you are
promised too
premise three well but you can't be
ultimately responsible for the way you
are because you'd have to be alright
they're all ready to kind of set
yourself up and that would lead to an
infinite regress
so you can't be ultimately responsible
for what you do
that's the argument
and why doesn't it have an impact on how
we
run things in society how we might run
our criminal justice system
yeah um i think there are sort of
actually there's three answers i want to
give one is my dad's answer a famous
paper called freedom and resentment by
pf strawson where he says
you know it's just not a real question
for us because our we're emotionally
tuned in such a way that we can't not
treat other people as free and feel
guilty ourselves
my answer is different because i think
he thinks the true
the true ground of the inability to give
up belief in free will is our attitudes
to others i think it's our own
experience of free will
and this on the side on the societal
matter
i think i had the pupil called saul
smilanski and i think he gives a good
answer which is
uh really it's a necessary illusion in a
way um
for some
simple reasons and some very complicated
reasons which we could
go into i mean one of the things is we
can't help believing we are free and it
would be it would be a tremendous
affront to our self-image and our
self-conception
if we were treated as if we had it
hadn't got it i better perhaps now also
give you the little toy story about why
we can't help believing it okay
i'm afraid i've not been very
imaginative i've had a story i tell for
ages but i'm going to tell it again
so
it's the evening of a national holiday
you've got you know it's a feast you've
got to spread
but you think really nice to have one
more cake on the table and everyone
comes tomorrow so you go to the shop
and you've got 10 pounds
and the shop's about to close
and there's one cake left in the shop
and it costs 10 pounds
and on the on the step of the shop is a
person collecting money for oxfam
for a charity
and you stand there and
existentially pragmatically
you cannot not feel yourself to be
absolutely radically free
to choose which thing to do
even if you know even if you believe
determinism is true and you believe and
that five minutes later you can turn
back round and say well what i did was
determined in that moment you are
radically existentially free
that's that's my argument that's why i
think it's primarily grounded in
first-person experience not in social
matters
is this a lesson for
other areas of philosophy as well is is
philosophy always doomed to only affect
how we think about things and not how we
do things not not ultimately change the
way we live our lives or the way we
treat others
it is a question whether you can
break out of
that belief and it could be that there
are certain spiritual
paths that have been taken in which this
has happened um i like to create this
guy called krishnamurti who said who
says roughly wait you know when you've
achieved this kind of spiritual
advancement you do not choose um
because as it were i mean the
hospitalization says god doesn't attack
according to freedom of the will how
could he i mean he he does what is his
best but that is not a constriction
um
so have i answered that question i'm
saying
is it even imaginable that someone could
completely throw off the belief in free
will
well i just don't know about that it
would probably take some pretty serious
spiritual practice but i don't suppose
it's impossible do you think this idea
that we have free will in the way that
we think about it today was always with
us was it always a human kind of concept
or is it a more modern idea
i think it's old but i think there's an
awful lot of really interesting cultural
variations there i mean
two just two simple examples
one and i don't know what it what what
it was like for these people when they
lived it but there was a very powerful
conception of fate in ancient greece and
you somehow accepted that
um well that was what that was your
destiny or you thought you know
character was destiny or something but
the other thing that interests me is um
some certain african tribes it might
have been the newer i i really don't
know but whereas something bad happens
to someone in the village and you know
you go to the elder and says what has
happened what has gone wrong
and
so at least sometimes it said it was
your fault you had a bad thought or
something and you caused disharm to this
other person
and there does seem to be
people are prepared to accept
responsibility for that
so what kind of conception of
responsibility would that be i mean i
don't know
um what about freedom of thought i mean
we're when we do philosophy we put
forward arguments we try and change each
other's minds even if we don't change
how we go on to act in the world we try
and follow the reasoning
but that's it we follow the reasoning
what are we ever trying to do but trying
to get what's true um we don't we
wouldn't want to be free not free to go
whichever way we want we want to go to
the truth and if i try to persuade you
it's because i'm going to of course it
never works in philosophy but i mean in
principle
uh what i would try to do is give you
arguments that you saw the force of and
that so so i i would be relying on if
you like a kind of deterministic system
in you
kind of your your susceptibility to
rationality as well
so it wouldn't
there i i mean it's interesting there is
a whole
kantian conception of freedom is
basically deter being determined by
reason
it's as it were that is true freedom is
to be to find what you do necessitated
by so that's it and enspinoza as well
but that does go against being
determined by causes by our physical
causes by the way
body our environment
i don't really see a conflict in fact
i think in my
book about original book long ago about
free will talk about the causality of
reason i mean you could go
you can go sort of naturalistic and
evolutionary about that um
uh
it was a really good idea if you were a
creature trying to survive in the world
that if there was a p and a p implies q
you went to q so i would say um i mean
there's some very dangerous there are
some tricky business i don't know if you
know about debunking arguments in ethics
but you know some very
some basic logical thinking there is
is is essentially irresistible you can't
do it you can't resist it unless you're
a
right-wing republican or something right
well of course i was going to say a lot
of people do resist it
yeah i believe all sorts of irrational
things okay so this is just a fact about
you know
the unlimited extent of human
irrationality um and here i always like
to quote this guy daniel kahneman do you
know about this
he's he's this behavioral economist well
he's a behavioral economist who won the
nobel prize with his colleague amos
tversky and they just there's a whole
book called thinking fast and slow which
is full of these extraordinary results
about how irrational we are and i cannot
i think i can quote word for word one of
the things he says it's something like
this
people will believe anything so long as
they're
backed up by a community of like-minded
people and so because this is why the
internet is
destroying us because for any crazy view
however you
you know in the old days you were in
your village with your crazy view and
you didn't know that anybody had it you
kept it under control but now on the
internet
you know there will be 30 000 people who
will holding it but no but it is it's
sort of as it were he's an experimental
psychologist who is basically
established people will believe anything
once once it's tribal once the group
gets behind it
so that's terrifying
and
of course completely
opposite of what i was saying before
because although we do have powerful
forces compelling us to be rational
especially when our lives are at stake
um we also have this terrible capacity
for irrational yeah so that's the
conflict i guess we get we have both the
pool of rationality and reason on the
one hand and the pull of
our social being our social existence
the way that we're socially determined
that might pull us in a different
direction and so which one of the two
which one of them well it's a mixture
and i'm actually one of the there's an
interesting essay by gk chesterton about
what it is to be mad and he said you
know sometimes what the madness consists
in the kind of crazy hyper rationality
where you
you you you you are the moves you're
making but the premises are crazy or
something like that so
we well we live in this
we live between these two and
stagger our way through
life in a state of deep confusion really
determined both by reason and by
natural forces and social forces yeah i
can see you you want to bring in social
i'd entirely
recognize them and agree with you about
that because just somehow it doesn't not
something that comes first to my mind
but of course
um i don't know i mean but on the issue
of cultural
relativism perhaps you're
um i do
i recognize it and see how powerful it
is but
i'm i'm also in some sense a humanist
and and i i use that word advisedly
because i i learned in australia that
it's a term of abuse among certain
people what is this i mean i believe in
certain human universals human nature
and i'm so i'm not a radical
you know
cultural relativist and um of course but
it's deeply determinative of how we
think
our social upbringing
in your
most recent book called things that
bother me death freedom the self etc
you have an interesting anecdote about a
past experience traveling the hippie
trail
in the late 60s early 70s
but you write about it as if it's about
someone else saying that you cannot
yourself really recall seeing yourself
there
is that experience to do with the fact
that personal identity as other
philosophers have argued in the past
isn't really real so there isn't really
a continued self or is this
a way that we can have some freedom we
can disassociate from our past and
reinvent ourselves oh i wouldn't think
that was a kind of freedom
um but
um
i think it's just
i'm just i'm one psychological type that
is and i have no sense of
identity
with the child i was i mean really not
even two days ago i
um
a radical human in well yeah in a way
it's funny you should say that because
yeah um there was a man called gaurangi
reese who
who wrote about this and was very
similar and he called his book a bundle
of sensations
um
i just don't have a sense of
[Music]
being there in the past or not pretty
vaguely in the future too
and
[Music]
there's a very powerful sort of
narrative school who thinks that no one
is like this and they also think that
it's really bad to be like this i'm just
saying i think we should be ecumenical
here and catholic and just say no it's
there are different types don't tell
don't say what we all have to be like
yeah so this is something that you've
also explicitly written about the
challenging the idea that we should see
our life as this kind of continuous
narrative having a
structure having a cohesion and feeling
bad about our lives when
that coherence seems to be lost that we
seem to have episodes of our lives that
don't really make sense in relation to
to other episodes why why do you think
that is that to do with i just think
that they shouldn't impose uh no there
was i think when i was writing that it
was almost universally accepted and
among a wide
spectrum of psychotherapists so what we
got to do is find your narrative you
know we've got to get you a narrative
and that makes you and it's just i've
had a lot of people
thank me for those things saying i
thought there was something wrong with
me because i didn't have it like that
and
i'm glad i'm not alone and so on um but
i'm certainly not saying that it isn't
that right and natural thing for some
people
it could well be um but yeah i mean i
have a sort of polemical streak here too
and i think that
there is no sort of
more
um fertile forum for self-deception
than in the
the narrative you may tell about your
own past life
you're very likely just to fantasize and
um i mean there's there's a and even
people like dennis will say things like
that that you know
we kind of paint the best picture which
isn't true either by the way there are
some people who have narratives in which
they're always putting themselves down
yeah um
what other what other big philosophical
illusions do you think we live with that
don't really make sense intellectually
but we somehow keep going with them free
will is one of them we talked about
having seeing our lives as having a
story a narrative i wouldn't say that
wasn't the illusion except you're very
unlikely to be true to yourself if
you're doing that um
um
well
the self what about the self i don't
know it's the trouble is that word is
too hopelessly vague to know whatever
whatever's meant by that
but i but the book i wrote about itself
i'd started saying i think there thought
to be three principal illusions
you know free will the self and love and
i thought probably love is the least
worst off i mean probably better off
than the other two
um
of course i think that everything
you know i have a brain and it's a
massive dispositions there's tremendous
continuity there in character
personality
and so that's all true but i don't so i
certainly don't think there's something
else called the self that's not physical
or um
personal identity help
i don't really know
what about the idea that there is an
ultimate truth out there as a way and
we're able to to get to that i just
think that i could i would say this but
i just take the word truth out
because truth implies a description or a
representation
and i just think look i think it's
actually a priori that is obvious that
well there is reality and to be is to be
a certain way that's a priority
necessarily so
if that's what if that's enough to say
that there is an ultimate truth i don't
think that we could ever achieve a
full description of it but um
there is i mean i i really entirely
happy with the famous phrase that so
many doubt and you might if you were
studying germany idealism the way things
are in themselves for me it's a priori
and trivial that there is a way things
are on themselves that is of course not
to say in any way
that we could ever
get at it or give a description of it or
um so i also you know i don't buy
schroedinger's cat type
thing saying it could be objectively
both or indeterminate
and in fact i only recently discovered
that schrodinger originally gave this
case to show that the absurdity yeah
exactly i'm very pleased to learn that
and what about self-knowledge are we
is that possible that was an early
aim of greek philosophy socrates starts
out by that imperative know thyself and
that should be the guides and the aim is
philosophy able to teach us about
ourselves
sure well but i think that's really
that's interesting because apparently
that originally was inscribed on the
wall of the temple
in egypt somewhere i've forgotten which
one carnek or something
and it's pretty clear that what it meant
when it was originally introduced was
not self-knowledge
it was know what it is to be a human
being to um and i find that very
pleasing actually i mean it's no it's
clear that and that and that
that emphasis persisted into the greek
tradition but it's clear also at least
that it began to be thought to be
something you should know more about
yourself as an individual but that
certainly wasn't its origin and i would
what would i say about that well of
course that's a good thing but
um
is it possible well you know then i
think well i'd sort of bring out my knee
to quotation you know man is a veiled
thing there are seven times was it seven
times seven levels
and we'll he can never know himself
um yeah we remain of necessity strangers
to ourselves yes things like that except
that i think it's another
it's another individual variable there
are people who
who just sort of do
they're not illusioned i feel about
themselves whereas most people are just
in fantasyland and here i and aris
murdoch is my great support you know
she talks about
the fat relentless eggo that comes along
with some [ __ ] about
it
is it it is a place of illusion she says
um and the other meaning of know thyself
in ancient greece was know your limits
and is that is that something that
philosophy can do yeah is that also well
that would that would flow straight from
know what it is to be a human being
and that would fit very well with
aristotle's stuff about the virtues this
is what it is what is a good life for a
human being you know without details
about your particular character and
uh yeah
know your limits absolutely
and one final question how has
philosophy impacted your life in a more
personal way
um
i think it's i see it very i'd have it
see it as a practice in a way i mean
nobody believes me when i say this but
when i first
wrote a book i thought well i don't know
now you get it published and i didn't it
wasn't really to get it published
because i thought people would read it
it was just
well i thought like a sort of
sufi potter in a market you know what
i'm doing is making pots here
and it's the practice rather than the
that sounds a bit sort of self-praising
or holy or something but um
and of course i do really care and i
hate it when people say there's no such
thing as consciousness
i want to
but
i guess it has happened i think it has
had a
a good detaching effect
i'm so
detaching in some way that is a good way
of course there could be bad ways of
detaching
um
yeah
well galen strobson thank you very much
for podcasts talks debates courses and
articles visit the institute of art and
ideas click the link on screen now to
iai.tv
you